the prosecutor is attempting to convince
a jury that there's no room for the
consideration of mitigating
circumstances when deciding on whether
nicholas cruz should be put to death for
the 2018 marjory stoneman douglas school
shooting given the premeditation and
cruelty of the crime i'm going to speak
to you
about the unspeakable
about this defendant's
goal directed
planned
systematic murder
mass murder
of 14 children
an athletic director
a teacher
and a coach
cruz had even recorded a cell phone
video days before boasting about his
chilling intentions hello
my name is nick
i'm going to be the next school shooter
of 2018.
my goal is at least 20 people
with an ar and some tracer rounds
some 50 family members of those killed
were in the courtroom as the prosecution
recounted cruz's methodical killing
spree the first witnesses were called
among them a teacher who said that
students were writing valentine's day
cards as characters in shakespeare's
romeo and juliet when the shooting began
it just kept going and going and going
a student who captured the scene on cell
phone video also spoke we were
just sitting kind of like sitting ducks
the footage she captured was played to
the jurors only the audio could be heard
in the public gallery which proved too
much for some
cruz's defense council has chosen to
defer an opening statement until later
in the trial however it's been reported
that among the mitigating factors the
defense would like to produce is
evidence of brain abnormalities crew
sustained as a fetus
after the shooting survivors formed the
gun control group march for our lives
now seen as a powerful voice in the gun
control debate parents of the dead also
remained vocal as seen just last week at
the white house when a bereaved father
heckled joe biden for not doing more
a jury must reach a unanimous decision
to recommend that nicholas cruz be put
to death otherwise he will face life in
prison without parole shiabratanzi al
jazeera